- But who's this?
- Don't know.
That's Klaus.
(upbeat jolly Christmas music)
- Mr. Klaus, you have a gift.
You were meant for
making toys so I figured,
if you donate your old toys,
I'll deliver them for free.
(relaxing melodic music)
- Well, I thought it was
like a good Christmas film,
like, it was like, for me,
it was like Rise of the Guardians,
but like, in like, a
different sort of way,
it was like around that context.
- Right, oh blimey!
Okay!
Are you a film critic?
Yeah!
- You should be a film critic!
(boy sighs)
Can you tell me a bit about
the film, what happens?
- So, basically, the end or the beginning?
No, don't!
- No spoilers!
(boy laughs)
It's not Breaking Bad.
- That's the postman.
- Hello!
Jesper, your handsome postman.
(wood breaking)
- About Jesper?
- Yeah!
- Yeah.
- Who was sent to...
I forgot the name of the village.
- He was a bit crazy.
- Who did Klaus remind you of?
- Santa!
- No, don't tell him anything.
(boy laughs)
- Santa Klaus!
- He reminds me a bit
of Santa Klaus as well.
Look, is it the beard?
- [Klaus] Let's go!
Ho, ho, ho.
- Wait, wait, wait!
(Klaus laughs)
Time out, really?
That's how you laugh?
- I thought it was, yeah, really good.
- It was really happy but
at the end it was quite sad.
- What happened?
- Not a word!
You just sit there!
Be all magical and awesome!
- Which bit was your favorite bit?
- When I met Santa.
- Why does he have a belt?
- Because otherwise his
trousers would fall down
and we'd see his pants!
We don't wanna see Jesper's pants, do we?
What the...?
- Loser!
- Oh yeah! Well, if I'm a loser,
then you're, you're a, you're
a, your not, you're too far,
you're gone!
- Have you asked Klaus for
anything for this Christmas?
- A drone.
- A drone!
Can you, can you sort a drone out?
- And me!
- And you, you want a drone as well?
Can you do two, two drones Klaus?
And what kind of message do
you think it gave everybody?
- It gave that you should
be good for Christmas.
- If you be kind to one person,
then the person you were kind to is kind
to someone else and it
just keeps on going.
- We need to show people
that a true selfless act
always sparks another.
(small girl giggles)
- If you tell one person, be nice to them,
they will be nice to another person.
- Christmas isn't just
about getting presents.
There is a deeper meaning to it.
- No!
(Jesper screaming)
- Ha, eat our snow you...
They're not attached.
Why aren't they attached?
I thought they were attached.
I would never in a million
years have done what I just did
if I didn't think these were attached.